if you had a friend who was a filmmaker
and let's say they were rejected by a
festival would you encourage them to
follow up with a letter polite letter
just inquiring us too well hey you know
why was this or you know maybe can you
take a second look or is it best to just
sort of let the chips fall where they
are no no I think it think it's good to
be as aggressive as possible I mean I
wouldn't say like take a second look
because you know it's just to be quite
honest I it won't happen I mean I don't
see programmers all right let me take
that back maybe some well and there's
instance that we've even had our early
years we were like kind of learning the
programming and we were growing so we
all of a sudden in seven days the
program and you know early on we we
actually programmed for a certain amount
of films and we realized we went back we
notified our one of everything and then
we looked at me said Oh actually we need
another like few hours of programming
another program to fill so we were short
so we actually did have to go back and
reevaluate some of those films that were
on the custom getting in and actually
ended up notifying them within me notify
them in the rain so we ended up putting
them in after we totally were not so
that happens sometimes but they didn't
follow up and say oh put me in a war no
take a second look or so it wasn't like
we respond to that per se but it was a
situation where we actually had to go
back after telling they didn't get in
and tongues are you know our error and
we actually you know decided to program
the film and that and that's you know
and it's not really the awkward because
it's great they're happy to get in we're
happy that we can program the films and
get him in and you know I wouldn't say
there's mistakes made it was just a
learning process of the time we had to
fill and I had a program and now that we
know what we're doing as far as the
programming and our link to the festival
that doesn't happen anymore but but uh
but yeah so I think went back to the
point of following up it's always good
to get on people's radars I mean no
matter what if he doesn't get responded
to okay well we get emails all the time
like that and sometimes we get the
respondent to people and you have
dialogue in and sometimes we don't want
to be made with some emails but I think
it's good to try I mean you know why not
you know I mean but again I don't know
what sane your second look there's very
rare opportunity that happening but it
is something that where you can get
feedback you can get feedback you know
people know will tell people when we can
you know certain few back by the phone
you ask in a good way and some people
get a little more upset when their
rights or in emails and that's and we're
not going to really we're not respond to
that I just fits it's not something we
want I want to go down that path i'm
thinking that negativity you want if
people ask a more respectful way and
looking for a sort of criticism that
someone would like to try to try to do
if we can so yeah so you know it's I say
yeah it's good it's good to follow up I
mean it again it's it's why not you
should always try to follow through when
it comes to the festival we like
filmmakers are more in tune to the film
to the festivals and also in like paying
attention to what we're doing and it
really like eager to reach out and are
more eager to like participate you know
then someone who just really doesn't pay
any attention or isn't sending emails or
is not very responsive you know we like
the interaction so I think there's
something to be said for people who are
you know to put themselves out there and
give it a shot you know
you